are you doing today I'm good how are you
right in first of all thank you so much
for coming in the studio today I so
appreciate it
I've been a big fan of your work for a
very long time and I'm very happy you I
appreciate you saying that
no no I'm totally serious i I'm just
gonna go backwards and start with I know
you're here for hi women but I was a
huge fan of Treme yeah thank you
it changed my perception of New Orleans
that show did it yeah
and and I don't want to put myself in
this but I used to go to New Orleans and
I'd go to the city for work and I'd be
like ok blah blah blah and then I saw
Treme and I'm like oh I have a
completely different look at this city
now yeah like it completely shifted
things did that happen with you from the
show it's funny you say New Orleans
where are you from one from all over but
right now in Los Angeles New Orleans
yeah unique take on them oh I see things
wrong all of that my second language
did it change New Orleans for me well I
yeah I mean I got to know it more and
more I mean I'm from the south so I was
familiar with New Orleans and had been
there a lot but my mother is from Mobile
Alabama which is a Gulf Coast town as
well it's actually where the first Mardi
Gras was so I'm very was very familiar
with it but going there with this story
of Treme and post Katrina the first few
months after Katrina would just I just
got to know the people and I got to know
the experience they went through and I
fell in love with New Orleans so hard
and in a moment's notice you can round
the corner and it will be the most
beautiful thing you've ever seen just
magic happens in that city around
another corner it'll break your heart I
mean it's so full there it's such an
incredible town a hundred percent and
that I learned that also from the show
but I'm also just a huge fan of David
Simon and you know I mean he's he's what
we call talented he is yeah he's he's
quite an auteur yeah he's amazing one of
the things I really also appreciated
about what HBO did with the show
is that the show never really broke out
in terms of ratings was some huge hit
but they really showed it love by
letting it breathe yeah tell the story
yeah I mean that's the thing with David
Simon and and especially in Treme I mean
he doesn't it doesn't hold anybody's
hand and walk them through the story
it's like you just have to patiently
sort of go on the ride and then you
start to experience it as a viewer so
that's the beauty of it I think
completely I'm jumping into why I get to
talk to you today which is the
highwayman I really enjoyed this movie
and as I was saying off-camera or we
were saying off-camera it's the kind of
movie that the studio's like used to
make but they don't really make anymore
it's like if you were saying like an old
school it is like a old school great
Hollywood movie I mean I we sat there i
was with my publicist and a friend and
we saw the screening of it earlier and
you just like it just is arresting i
mean john lee hancock is amazing
filmmaker and the movie just you just
sit back you're like get the popcorn
this is gonna be amazing for people that
have not seen the trailer it's gonna be
on netflix soon but i hate asking the
generic thing but talk a little bit
about how you've been saying it to your
friends like what it's about the
highwayman is about the two detectives
that were brought out of retirement the
two ex Texas Rangers highwayman that
were brought out of retirement to
capture to track and capture and kill
Bonnie and Clyde and you know usually we
see this romanticized story of Bonnie
and Clyde and the glamour and you know
the brutality of all of that but now we
have it from the perspective of the
actual detective who was able to catch
them because they were uncatchable by
the FBI by local state police everything
it was two years I believe they were you
know on this murder spree killed 13
people something like that but they just
were uncatchable well the thing about it
in the film does a great job with it is
that people loved them even though they
were brutally killing people that the
public was fascinated by them and you
know revered them there's a scene in the
film where you know they're going to the
pharmacy and people are like wanting
pictures and you know it's it was it
it's just crazy
yeah they are the the early form of
celebrity I
I I don't know why I think well they
they took pictures of themselves when
they found a camera at one of the
locations they were they were in and
they left the camera there and I think
when the police got to that location
they then took that film and processed
it so that's what made it into the
papers these sort of bragging photos of
them and very stylish clothes and and
bonny with a cigar and a machine gun and
you know so they it sort of gave them
this weird celebrity allure and
supposedly they were you know helping
those that were being hurt by the system
or what-have-you but that wasn't really
the case and they just sort of became
glamorized a little bit and they were
young and attractive and but yeah it's
interesting you are married to Kevin
Costner in the movie and I'm just
curious I'm a huge Kevin Costner fan
that's a tough day at work I was going
to say no how much and I'm sorry for
asking this but how much did you pay to
be in the movie I couldn't believe I got
to be Kevin Costner wife it was so
exciting I worked with John Lee Hancock
before and the blindside and and he
asked me to come along and do this role
and the script is amazing
the story's fantastic but you know any
time before this has been just untold
story you know it's it's riveting but
then you know Kevin Costner I mean he's
an amazing actor and he's an iconic
movie star as soon as he shows up on the
on the screen you're like oh I'm in you
know I just to get to play his wife and
to to work with him it's like no better
dance partner now did you find you've
been in some cool stuff but did you find
on this film that more people wanted to
visit you when you were filming no
because it was in Shreveport Louisiana
it's hard to get to you and I shot it
for like him a week okay I know people
like call me when you get back had it
been more a longer shoot I definitely
would have had some people interested in
visiting said I've been too sure my mom
for one oh I was gonna say she report
I've been there and it is definitely out
of the way in terms of it is it takes a
bit to get there just
sweet sweet town I love Louisiana so we
know that but it's a sweet town but it
was it's a little couple of planes to
get you there yeah so the other thing is
that there's some great chemistry
between Kevin and woody great chemistry
between Kevin and Kym that's also true
but I would say that I'm a big fan of
the two of them yeah they're great
together right I was just gonna say that
when you find out how early on we so did
did you find out Kevin was in it and
then like I'm just curious the order of
the casting and we sort of like oh yes
this I'm in this yeah I mean look I'll
probably do anything John Lee Hancock
asked me to do I think he's an
incredible filmmaker but the whole
package with Kevin and woody together is
just incredible I've never met woody I
still haven't met woody I'll meet him
tonight I hope tonight's the premiere
yeah yeah I never picked that I was
gonna make a thing that I've never know
what what night the premieres are here
for the festival but your heads probably
spinning a little bit I want to
definitely touch on something else I was
also a huge fan of debt Deadwood and I
lose one they made the movie and I it
was one of those things where I just
never thought it was going to happen you
too yeah we've kept on reporting on it
like oh there's a script and I'm like
it's never happening there's a script
it's never happening oh wait they're
filming this yeah like so could you talk
a little bit about when you actually
heard where this is actually being made
well from the moment we were prematurely
canceled we kept hearing rumors that oh
well they want to do a couple of movies
they want to do a movie this that and it
would happen for a few years and then
all of a sudden you would hear
absolutely not it's not happening and
you know your dreams were crushed
because we all loved doing it it was an
incredible experience in you know the
product itself speaks for itself it's a
it's a remarkable piece but the actual
process was incredible for us the actors
and working with David Milch and the
writers and and just performing together
I mean that troupe of actors is I mean
phenomenal so you know that we went for
years and then there'd be another rumor
and then they'd be squashed again and
then so finally they called him you
put pins in us gave us dates and said is
she available we're like yeah and then I
mean I said I wasn't gonna believe it
till I was on set and wearing a top hat
but we did it we did it and it's great I
haven't seen it but the script was great
everyone was great you know we're a lot
older we're a lot older in it but that's
good for the story what was gonna say I
think that and I could be mistaken that
the movie sort of acknowledges the time
has passed or my yeah does yeah and so
what was your reaction though the first
time you get the script you obviously
reading it you know your character you
know this world was it weird like talk a
little about your reaction reading the
script of the first time and for fans of
the series what do you what can they be
looking forward to my experience of
reading the script was pure joy because
from the from word one you're just in it
it's the same beautiful prose it's the
same complicated sad hilarious dangerous
characters it's the same beautiful
dialogue it's I mean from the moment it
starts you're just you're back there
right it's perfect
I thought the script was incredible it
has so much to offer I can't say too
much you know time has has has passed
it'll you know there's a lot of growth
and Deadwood the the the buildings are
made out of stone some of the buildings
we've the town had suffered a fire which
really burned the town down from one end
to the next that really happened
you know there's telephones there's
restaurants right but it's still a muddy
muck ether over don't get me wrong I
swear there I've done a lot of set
visits I've been very lucky if I had
ever got invited on that set I probably
would have just you know very very happy
I'll say it like that people visiting
there right I would imagine that that's
one that do you without going in any
further in terms I don't want anything
obviously spoiled or you to say anything
but do you think it's the kind of thing
where you know it could continue or do
you think like if the movie was you know
well-received like you could do more of
it or do you think that this is a wrap
if you would I don't know I mean I don't
know I think anything is is you know
we're seeing everything you know able to
be rebooted and continued and stuff I
think they're there's so much story we
could tell you know I think it would be
about the success of this and I think it
would be about getting everyone together
again and and David feeling like he's
got the story he wants to write you know
but there I think there's so much to
tell I think we all felt so blessed to
be back together that I think we'd all
love to do it I'm basically out of time
but I just want to touch him one other
thing real quick I'm a huge David
Fincher fan huge me too why wouldn't you
be I'm very curious if you could just
talk a little bit about getting to work
with him and what you took away from
that process because he's such an
interesting filmmaker and I mean in my
opinion one of the most brilliant minds
working behind the camera
he really is David Fincher is one of the
most brilliant minds working on the
camera I adore him I adored the
experience of gone girl it was
challenging for all of us I mean Ben
included like we all were like at the
end of the day like oh my god it's so
hard because he's so specific and he
does so many takes and he nuances
everything and but but he pushes you and
he pushes himself on a daily basis to be
better and it's so fun he loves actors
Fincher loves actors and he feels like
hey we've spent all this money writing
this script building these sets getting
our locations finding the building the
costumes all this stuff casting it so
I'm gonna do two takes when I get the
actors here and no way we're gonna spend
as much time we're gonna make it right
and make it great and so he really does
push you in ways that that you don't
really get pushed like since you were
maybe an acting school so for me I take
some of his things he sort of retaught
me and taught me and that filming I take
it with me I keep it in mind when I'm
working now it's so interesting I've
spoken other actors makes you better he
makes you better
I've spoken other actors that have
worked with him and they've all said
something similar to what you said there
must be something he tells you because
I've heard so many people say it's all
about having more time on set and I've
heard him say to me I'd rather have less
crane shots and more time on set because
a crane costs $1,000 yeah
thousand dollars rather of a meal
penalty when we're going right yeah you
know but the thing that I've heard also
is he has a very long schedule to allow
for the ability to do 30 or 40 takes or
whatever he wants to do so talk a little
about that aspect of the filming process
that it's a little bit more of a
marathon than maybe you'd normally do
yeah no I mean you shoot at a very small
amount of pages in a day like I said we
will go long takes like 50 takes on a
master as you could start getting in
closer you do less takes and you know
we'd start to wager like with Ben and
Patrick few get we'd say okay how many
takes you think it's gonna take you for
your close-up and you know Ben would say
oh I don't know you're kind of in the
zone it's probably gonna take nine or
you know we'd start to gamble and see
who could pick out how long it was gonna
take to get our close-ups you know but
but for me it's also wasn't like it's
not like he does take after take just to
throw things out there he's nuancing it
he's making it more and more specific
he's seeing things and trying different
things so you're challenged with each
take we're actors we like to act so for
me I don't know what problem with it and
no one we were that I was working with
did but I think he's he's already got
the person he wants for the role you're
kind of already throwing down the middle
but it is about just discovering new
things and and honing it in yeah you did
great work in that film like I said
before I'm a big fan of your work I'm so
happy you got to come in today and for
everyone who's watching right now i
really recommend high women when it's on
Netflix is it the 29th what it's it airs
on Netflix March 29th and before that
we'll be in a few select theaters here
and there across the states thank you so
much for coming in yeah thank you
pleasure to meet likewise
you